you can monetize education itself you
can sell education but I think the smart
move is that you give away the secrets
you sell the implementation take all the
content you would normally sell as your
course and give it all away for free
where do you think some of the best
smartest materials get pumped out from
Harvard Business Review people cite
their stuff they make content to Market
that they are thought leaders in the
space the implementation they sell is
that we will Hands-On teach you how to
do it and so if I were selling the
ability to sell then I would give away
the course as content through all the
different platforms I possibly could and
the implementation would be let me
listen to your sales calls give you
feedback in real time and then monitor
your performance over that period so
that you become a salesperson